Bây giờ, phụ Pakistan nghe hàng lòng thống mời, kênh báo nguy cơ sợi ra trên trang toàn dị ạng bởi áp cả ní stan,
nếu vòng hoa đam đáng dễn ra tại thành phố I stan Buun của thuật nghĩa kì không gà được thoại thuật, bản lâu dài.
Pháp biểu với chuyện hiện nước, buổi trường của Phòng Pakistan, Khao Wajra, Mohama, Asi, cho biết,
cả Istramar Bán và Kha Buun đã tên thu lạnh nếu bản đất được tại đô 2 hồn mùi tham thống mời,
đông thời đàn ra tại đi bán, dòng nguy cụ mong mùi hoa bình, tuy nhiên ở nhìn mạnh nếu tiến chính đầm phá thích bài,
Pháp kì Stan sẽ buộc phải lựa trọn phương án của Nthil.
Bông ra phán tại Istramar Bán đồng ngày 20 hong thống mời, có sự chung dăng của thuật nghĩa kì và kata.
Tập chung sây dựng gơ trời giám só, và kia dài thỏa thuật nguy bản tạm thời,
đây được xem là lỗi lịch mại dọ quan trọng, nhằm chấm rất tăng hàng,
sau lọt ra tránh đất mẫu hồi đậu tháng mời,
khi đó tài li bán tấn công các chút kiểm soát của các khí sang để đáp trả được không biết được cho,
là gió Istramar Bán tính hàng trọng đỏ, khiến hàng trục bý sĩ hai bên thêm mạc,
và nhiều cơ khó bình dợi phải đọng gơ.
Và ký Stan như làng cá buộc tài li bán trọa phép các nhỏ vụ trang,
dùng lạnh thổ ác kánh đi Stan làm nợ nở, để tiến hàng tấn công xuyên mời,
trong kì chính quyền cá buồn chỉ trách kháng đậu quân sự của các khí sang là vi vàng trục quên.
Cả hai bên được không định sẽ sang bảo vệ lạnh thổ nếu đang phán tệ Istramar Bún không đã kết quả.